is Jordan Peterson still in this whole
mess with the People's Republic of
Canada yeah Justin Trudeau do you have
any thoughts on that or yeah yeah of
course I mean I I'm
I just think it's a classic example of
what happens when
government gets too powerful and you
have an ideology that believes that they
can engineer equality and which really
means the only way to do that is by
force I mean that's what happens if
you're gonna if you're gonna enforce
your your what you believe to be true
because you figured it out for all of us
because you figured out the gender thing
that the rest of us been living our
lives but you figured that out
apparently your experts have all the
answers your experts have all the
answers on global warming we're going to
die at any minute and all this stuff and
all of this is settled science by the
way and all this is not up for debate
we'll just stop that I can always tell
when people don't really have good ideas
when they refuse to debate or they try
to silence you that's always a good
indication when they're afraid to
actually open themselves up and maybe
realize that their ideas aren't fully
formed maybe there's a better idea out
there and all that but that you know
Justin Trudeau is not yeah interested
what is actually happening with he's
being he's being asked to take
social media
um re-education programs of source no he
apparently the the board of
psychiatrists in in the gutless board of
psychiatrists in Canada is basically
being told that I mean they basically
said you will lose your license if you
don't take our course and you have to
pay for it and then we'll tell you when
we think you're better it's an outrage
one complaint submitted a full
transcript of Peterson's four-hour
interview with Rogan Lester claiming
that his statements on faulty climate
change models and the dangers of
promoting radical gender Theory violated
the professional code of conduct for
psychologists accredited with the ocp
Peterson stands accused of undermining
his profession by speaking on areas well
outside his area of competence and
making problematic unethical and
professional unprofessional comments
it's amazing yeah he's got to take a
remedial course on social media
Communications with a board-issued
therapist it's like a I mean it sounds
like a joke
but this is what happened in all these
socialist Utopias this was what happened
during the Communist Revolutions in all
the countries whether it was Yugoslavia
whether it was
um you know Hungary whether it was the
Soviet Union of course this is the kind
of [__] you live in anything with
re-education you're saying this doesn't
happen in America
I'm saying this could happen in America
very easily if we're not happy right now
you don't think it's happening like you
know how some of these guys are like
well you listen you know I I was asked
to take a six-week class on being a
nympho and I'm fully ready now to make
my marriage work hey you're required to
take a six-week course why it's not good
to uh uh you know do this or it's less
I'm less concerned animals or doing that
or well I'm less concerned with whatever
that is I'm I'm more concerned with how
what they're doing in our schools you
see so so when certain things like
gender Theory become settled science and
now you want to teach uh kindergarteners
to third grade about sexual orientation
and gender
before they even have a context for what
the world is about and someone like to
Santa says this is this is not gonna fly
let kids be kids and figure some other
things out first please and let parents
deal with that maybe and they they call
it a don't say Gator yeah and call it a
an appalling anti-trans Bill Etc that
narrative just doesn't fly dude you you
didn't think about this stuff until
about 20 minutes ago anyway so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]